Instagram came out of one wanting to be
my own boss I was like you know what I
want to work for myself I want to work
on ideas I really hope I'm gonna make
money Instagram a company with only 13
employees bought today by Facebook for 1
billion dollars let's talk about 700
million monthly users you guys set out
to do this six and a half years ago
imagine you started a company today and
you later on sold that company for 1
billion dollars pretty good right but
what if I told you that it took you only
three years to sell that company that's
the story of Instagram and it's one of
my favorite stories to tell people not
only because it's kind of yeah it's a
unicorn company no they they they got so
much money in such a short amount of
time and blew up mostly because there's
one huge lesson that can be taken out of
the story of Instagram that can be
applied to business it can be applied to
your life and I have always applied it
ever since learning about it into
everything that I do so without further
ado this is the story of Instagram how
one decision created a company that is
worth billions
[Music]
on December the 30th 1983 Kevin Systrom
was born to his parents Douglas and
Diane sister on in Massachusetts
Middlesex County now kevin was a pre
ordinary kid he worked at a vinyl record
store during high school and he was also
a big fan of doom 2 which is a video
game that I'm sure quite a lot of people
will be familiar with and it was in fact
from doom 2 that Kevin grew a love for
computer programming also Kevin really
loved to read which is shout-out to my
readers because yeah if you know me you
know I love reading and I always
recommend it so read I was a kid that
just wanted to play with computers and
the second I learned that can you to
program them to do things I got hooked I
got like the idea of writing programs to
then do things and then have those
things be useful was like an idea that
like it caught on very quickly Kevin
later on went to attend Stanford
University
and he later met a guy called Mike
Krieger but that was it they met briefly
and there wasn't anything crazy that
happened there but my krieger went on to
become the co-founder of Instagram with
him but we're jumping ahead of the guns
let's get back to the story
now during Stanford Kevin was approached
by another young entrepreneur who
approached him and asked him hey Kevin
I've got a business would you like to
help me out with it the entrepreneur was
Mark Zuckerberg and the business was
Facebook but Kevin declined
doing it remember meeting one of my
mentors and I was like hey like said you
this Facebook thing and I remember the
person saying that's a fad it's also
important to note that during his time
at Stanford
Kevin Systrom attended what is called
the Mayfield's fellow program which is
like this program where you are kind of
selected to work at a startup and they
kind of train you and show you the ropes
and it kind of gives you the really good
work experience that you'd want I prayed
that they would take me because I was so
excited about entrepreneurship and they
let me in
on that program Kevin worked at a
company called Oh do an O do was the
company that later went on to become
Twitter so it's like a social media was
literally following this guy forever now
after the university keeping up with his
passions Kevin went on to work had a
tech startup by day he was working and
by night he was learning to code it also
just so happened the Mike Krieger the
guy who attended Stanford along with
Kevin and they met briefly was in the
area also doing the same thing and
eventually the details are kind of
blurred but they ended up meeting and
having a chat in a cafe first meeting
was where was it was it at a at that
breakfast place
yep just through cafe yeah we were just
for you cafe is now getting free
advertising and in that cafe they came
up with the idea for an app but it was
an Instagram
now Kevin had the idea for an app called
bourbon and if you've heard of bourbon
or you're probably one of the few
because most people have never heard of
bourbon so you're probably wondering
what the hell are these guys doing cray
in bourbon when they're supposed to be
praying Instagram will get there
Mike Riga here's this idea they're
singing the calf and he goes yeah I like
it
I got excited enough that I think I'd
yeah I came up with Kevin I was like
look if you ever do this for real like
let's have a conversation and I think
that first meeting we had about it
actually I was like count me interested
like I'm I'm excited enough to do it and
you know how like the the cliche of your
life flashing before your eyes like my
future flash before my eyes we're
talking to Kevin right then a bourbon
was a check-in app with the photo
sharing feature where you would go to a
bar or restaurant and you would take a
picture of when you're there and it
would kind of be like hey guys I was
here and this is the picture that I took
I think even I don't know how bourbon
works but it wasn't anything like
Instagram it's much more like a check-in
app so Kevin goes around trying to get
investments for his new I did I went to
a bar where a bunch of investors were
getting together and like I kind of
mingled around the room and you know
people were kind of showing their
prototypes on their phones to different
investors and I showed it to this one
investor his name Steve Anderson who was
one of our first investors Oh Steve his
about this idea and he says you know
what guys I like it so I'm gonna put
$50,000 towards your idea that's a huge
huge amount of money and in Silicon
Valley when someone gets wind of an
investment like that going around
suddenly everybody is coming up to you
trying to get some trying to get a piece
of the pie because they think that if
someone's willing to make that kind of
investment and you've got something big
on your hands so it wasn't long before
Steve Anderson's initial investment of
$50,000 turned to 250,000 dollars on top
of that the venture capitalist company
andreessen horowitz added onto that
investment an additional two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars so essentially
you've called these two guys
you are starting a relatively new
company with half a million on their
shoulders and you're probably wondering
with that much money what the hell
happened to Bourbon
no matter how much money investors throw
at you there's just one thing that they
can't change and that's how the market
reacts to your product or whatever it is
that you're selling people and it turns
out that bourbon didn't have as good as
a V response
you see the Bourbon app only really got
to about a hundred users and that was it
Kevin and Mike were both realizing this
very soon that bourbon really wasn't
going anywhere we were both kind of
burned out we had decided that bourbon
wasn't gonna do anything we had you know
four hundred and ninety five thousand
dollars left in the bank because five
thousand dollars to buy a couple of
computers right so then what was the
catalyst what changed everything for
these guys you see Kevin and Mike did
something incredibly incredibly
important instead of asking man why
aren't there more people joining bourbon
we need more customers we need well what
kind of what kind of marketing should we
do to bring in more customers instead of
asking those questions they asked the
one question which is the most important
question they went directly to their
customers and they said why do you guys
even use bourbon in the first place and
what they noticed was almost all of them
said they didn't care for the check-in
aspect but they much rather preferred
the photo-sharing aspect the best thing
for any entrepreneur is failure and for
us it was the lack of momentum we I
mentioned we got to we've got to about a
hundred users using this app don't ask
why people don't use your startup ask
why the people who continue to use your
startup keep using it and when we looked
at our our user base our whole hundred
people each of them loved the photo
aspect
[Music]
Kevin and Mike took the message and they
realized Bourbon isn't gonna work we
need to change up we're creating
something new and it's gonna be a photo
sharing app now don't get it twisted
because Instagram was certainly not the
first photo sharing app to be published
on the App Store there were many others
but the difference between them and
Kevin and Mike is that Kevin and Mike
always asked themselves what problem are
we solving the way we set ourselves
apart from the crowd was focusing on
problems so many entrepreneurs today our
technology and searching for problem not
the other way around
if stuff doesn't exist and it's a
problem that can be solved aka like the
experience sucks then that's what you
should go do there were a lot of
check-in apps there were a lot of
planners and meet up things and group
chat things but there was no solution
for posting great photos to like lots of
friends all at once and later on when
Kevin was on a vacation with his
now-wife he had the following
conversation with her and I was like oh
so you're excited about this new app
we're building we haven't called it
Instagram yet she was like yeah but I
don't think I'm gonna use it cuz my
photos aren't that good it's like okay
well why don't you think your photos are
good and she's like well your friends
you know you post these amazing photos
and they're all like filtered and stuff
and I was like oh that's because they
use filters and she goes oh well you
should probably add filters and we came
back from that walk I went straight to
the room and I just like got on my
laptop and I made the first filter which
was ex-pro to off the craying the filter
he goes to a taco stand he takes out his
phone and he takes a picture of his dog
and that photo became the first-ever
photo on Instagram and you can still
find it to this day so Kevin rushes back
home after his vacation to Mike and they
guessed I'd immediately working on
Instagram and from around the time that
they started building it - when they
released it on October the 6th 2010 it
was about eight weeks worth of work and
as soon as they released it it blew the
hell up within about 24 hours they had
25,000 users roughly
and if you've ever tried praying an app
you will know how incredibly huge that
number is learn the fact that off the
one month they had 1 million users using
their app and so two years after
launching this incredibly successful app
after countless celebrities like Justin
Bieber Snoop Dogg even Obama joined on
the app there was another entrepreneur a
well known entrepreneur who sent
something very familiar with why
Instagram was doing
of course this person was Mark
Zuckerberg and when he made Facebook he
saw a similar trend in how there was a
burst of users going towards Facebook he
saw that exact trend in Instagram and so
he decided he wanted a piece of the pie
and to put a long story short he came to
Kevin and Mike and he said guys I will
buy your company for 1 billion and Kevin
and Mike agreed if you were going to
sell your company
the idea is to sell your company that's
to a company that's gonna be a rocket
ship and I remember Mike and I talking
about like do we believe that by being
part of this larger company Instagram
can reach an even higher potential even
more quickly because they believe that
Facebook would take Instagram to higher
levels which he was right about
Instagram at the moment his worth about
a hundred billion so in other words
Facebook a hundred xed their investment
pretty good but here's the thing none of
this would have been possible if it
wasn't for this one crucial crucial
moment during the creation of Bourbon
when they were faced with a decision
between two paths to pivot or to
persevere
the key to entrepreneurship is failing
really quickly let's just talk about the
premise that most successful things are
pivots pivoting is changing your idea
based on analyzing what you've been told
or what what data you can gather from
what you've been doing so far and going
towards what it seems would be the best
choice out of that data
persevering is continuing with it there
are so many people that if they had
bourbon in their hand they would have
said along with that investment money of
almost half a million they would have
said no we're gonna keep going with
bourbon we're gonna keep we're gonna try
and get this thing off his feet but Mike
and Kevin decided to pivot and that is
the single most important decision in
instagrams history riveting is not a bad
thing you see some people would have
looked at Mike and Kevin situation and
they would have said right when they
were at that boiling point with bourbon
way wasn't working they would have said
I if you guys stop now you're quitting
and that kind of advice
would have kept them stuck for a very
very long time there's nothing wrong
with changing an initial idea that
didn't work out for you as I said if it
wasn't for that single factor Instagram
wouldn't have been what it is today and
it's easy to look at all the money and
all the crazy glamour and whatnot that
they got from it and how huge event
habits become but at the end of the day
always remember pivot or persevere the
option exists there every point in time
so that pretty much concludes the story
of Instagram and more importantly the
lesson that you can draw from it pivot
or persevere and if you enjoyed the
video please do give it a like a thumbs
up whatever the hell you want to call it
and give it a subscribe it helps a ton
and comment if you made it to the end
know these videos along if you make it
to the end you are an amazing amazing
person let me know down below I respond
to all of it I promise
check out some of my other videos as
well for more kind of editing like this
and videos in this style I'm sure you
will enjoy them and stay tuned because
there's some awesome awesome stuff on
the way but without further ado peace my
friends
[Music]
you